tenemos que seguir en la lucha porque la
única opción que tenemos
por un lado pues está esta ley lo único
que va a hacer es aumentar los abortos
clandestinos y la mortalidad materna
relacionada con los abortos clandestinos
y poner en riesgo la vida y la salud de
las mujeres en la ley es tan restrictiva
que ni siquiera permite un aborto
después de las seis semanas en casos de
violaciones esta es una ley que
definitivamente viola muchísimo los
derechos igualmente se espera como ya
hizo un llamado desde la casa blanca al
presidente y la vicepresidenta que el
congreso actúe y que se hable de la
codificación del caso de robo
paula ávila a guillén también se refirió
de los incentivos que da esta ley a
aquellas personas que denuncian a las
mujeres que aborten después de las seis
semanas
esta es una de las partes más drásticas
y más absurdas de esta ley que permite
que cualquier persona pueda poner una
denuncia de una posible sospecha de un
médico o de que alguien le ayuda a una
mujer a tener un aborto nosotros hemos
visto las repercusiones de leyes
similares como las del salvador y el
resultado de eso es que mujeres terminan
en la cárcel por perdidas espontáneas de
sus embarazos porque cualquier tipo de
emergencia obstétrica se vuelve un
posible crimen y esto realmente va a ser
de ese desbastador y es un ataque muy
directo a la comunidad médica y
obviamente a las mujeres